Her low freak bitches.
Now,
let me ask you a question.
I know you,
you don't,
yeah.
You're not going to say,
yeah,
I know Jamie's been watching lately.
Jamie,
tell me the truth as Pete rose been killing it lately.
Tell me the truth.
J Rose,
what do you mean he been killing it on national TV p baseball player.
What's he doing?
He's doing like this.
I'll analyze it,
but they got him and Alex Rodriguez.
Oh my God,
it Joe Rogan.
You've got watch.
This is 2016 Pete rose with a bow tie because Pete rose,
no matter,
I've never been mad at p rose.
Pete rose was one of my heroes though.
Yeah,
Pete rose is one of my heroes.
I've never gotten mad at Pete rose.
He's human,
but in a way how they treat him.
But he was a junkie and he was a piece of shift for a while.
Like he was a gambling junkie,
you know,
he was a piece of shift for a while,
but enough,
he's fucking Pete rose dog and he's in,
I'm telling you,
I watched this show one night and I was dying.
How funny he is.
Like how crazy is I think going to keep them around Fox.
I hope they fucking do well.
Did you ever watch him Joe?
Anything looking at both times.
That's classic.
How old is Pete Rose Now?
Fifties or 60s.
Sixties.
I just feel bad that you know,
there was a,
all the speculation that he had done.
75.
Wow.
Yeah,
there was all that speculation that he had um,
gambled on his own team,
but I don't think that was ever shown.
Listen,
you have to assume I'm a gambling.
Can you do me a favor of Jamie?
Can you put up for Joe Rogan?
Can you put up Pete Rose Against Ron Boon and the all star game?
This is when you,
I had to show people at a ball one that I go,
you youngsters never know Pete Rose's.
No.
Let me just show you a Pete Rose's.
Pete Rose Tackles Ron.
Boom.
But the beauty of this,
it's an all star game.
You never saw this German?
No.
Look at you.
You're beside yourself.
Oh No,
no,
because I'm like get allergies is shit.
You have to look at this.
Look,
all right,
this is this guy.
How he played like this guy wasn't American savage.
Oh yeah.
Right.
He's a barbarian.
Charlie Hustle.
This is crazy.
This is still the crime.
Look at it.
Oh my God.
He just took him out.
He tells him,
don't ever block that fucking basic gun cock sucker.
Oh Shit.
Like he was the last of the real fucking Americans.
He fucked up.
Yeah,
I'm a gambler.
And he wrecked that dude.
He literally tackled him.
Oh my God.
Full shoulder down.
Now here's the beauty.
If you put on yelled at them,
let me tell you something.
1973,
I was 10 years old.
I went to see the mets against the Cincinnati reds.
I was in my fucking haven.
It was the fucking all star game.
It was the National League,
uh,
Eastern Conference.
And he beat up but house and his second,
I left there,
look at us.
so fucking happy.
I went there with my mom,
my stepdad.
We was sitting behind Tony Perez family and Pete rose is beaten up on bud house.
And I left that with my fucking Dick hard.
And that,
and I could chicken pox.
I had the chicken pox.
I went to that game with the fucking chicken pox.
So here's my question to you.
Go ahead.
How come this can't happen today?
Because how come the guy can't run into the guy at home base today?
That would be a much suspension,
three months suspension,
suspensions,
nothing,
right?
Nothing.
And that was one of the greatest,
look at that team right there.
That's playing.
That's one of the greatest.
You'll never see anything like that.
Yeah,
that's New York City.
This is fucking tremendous.
Oh my goodness.
This is awesome.
What a fight.
Oh,
did they cut it off?
What a terrible time to edit it.
That was just,
it was just getting good.
Yeah.
P has gotten a bunch of his fights,
right?
Fist fights he used to tackle you at second,
but you know,
he played baseball.
He played,
you know,
Cincinnati,
somebody would get hurt on Cincinnati.
Reds and bench would automatically go to first and plumber would play like a
plumber was like fucking God.
And he sat by,
you know,
it was just a Trump meta.
When me and Goldberg get together,
we talk about the Cincinnati reds cause I grew up on them.
But at this point I think I don't give a fuck about the hall of fame for Pete
Rose.
I know he gambled on his own team,
but if you know any,
if you know any history of gambling and professional sports,
guess what?
Joe Rogan,
the all losers,
they all lose a ton of money,
tons of money from Archie fleets to to fucking Pete rose.
There was another one that used to bet on,
you know the arch sleets still didn't get caught Baeten on himself,
but he,
he,
he's known to fucking lose everything.
I'm professional gambling.
These guys all called right from downstairs only they think they're the only
ones who did it.
Is that what you're trying to tell me?
I have a brother who's a fucking moron,
but he's married to my sister and I know he's a dumb fucking loser gambler.
I can't call him and say to him,
listen,
fucking Malique shore.
His ankles hurt until I bet against them,
you know,
whatever I can,
you know what I'm saying?
I mean a lot of fucking people do it.
Pete rose,
they hate him.
He used to tell him,
fuck you.
When you play like that,
what do you think?
You don't think your rest of your life is telling people to go fuck themselves.
Who does that in 1973 in an all star game?
It doesn't mean anything.
So the players didn't like him like that.
He,
he was against the fucking system like since day one.
Then he went and he became a player.
She,
when he was gambling on himself,
he was a player manager.
Supposedly.
What's,
Oh,
okay.
A player manager.
But me and my gambling mind,
he been gambling the whole time.
You know what I'm saying?
Where I start.
It's not to say that it just,
he just started gambling one day.
No,
he had been gambling the whole time because in the 70s it was a little less
frowned upon.
What do you like to the,
I got this horse in the third row,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
And Day that basketball,
but football back becomes a baseball bat.
Well,
people had bookies were really common.
Common.
Everybody had a book.
It's less common today.
Yes.
Today,
because everything's done on computers and people could do stuff like that.
But,
uh,
30 years ago,
August,
the skinny guy would look at the bar.
You went to [inaudible] and that's the book.
What do you want to do?
You gave him cash after three or four or five fucking seat a week,
he starts letting you bet on credit.
Okay.